le premier ministre avait déjà annoncé
ses couleurs nous savons aussi que une
relance plus propre plus verte va faire
parti des opportunités que nous avons
pour bâtir une économie plus forte
radio canada a appris que le transport
électrique sera un élément clé de la
relance vert du gouvernement
énoncé dans le discours du trône ottawa
veut bâtir une nouvelle chaîne
industrielle canadienne mobiliser les
secteurs minier et manufacturier de
l'extraction de lithium de cobalt et de
nickel à la production de batteries et
de véhicules électriques au canada
ottawa voit grand et veut attirer les
investissements
le canada dispose des ressources
naturelles et de la main d'oeuvre
qualifiée rappelle le ministre de
l'innovation à un secteur en pleine
expansion qui pourrait créer des
dizaines de milliers d'emplois selon lui
au même moment
ottawa de concert avec queen's park est
prêt à investir jusqu'à 500 millions de
dollars pour que les installations de
ford à houppeville soit convertie pour
la production de véhicules électriques
l'incertitude plane sur l'avenir de
l'usiné et des négociations se
poursuivent une autre indication
qu'ottawa fait de ce secteur une
priorité
seulement avoir un secteur mais une
variété de secteurs une approche louable
mais pour atteindre des cibles
climatique ambitieuse le canada doit
avoir une stratégie beaucoup plus vaste
peut passer au secteur du bâtiment donc
de fermer les rénovations 3 qu'on sait
que c'est très porteur pour l'économie
et pour l'emploi
il ya aussi tout le secteur du transport
collectif et actif
l'opposition reste prudente et attend
des gestes concrets
c'est juste pour l'instant des mots pts
et la balle adverses dans le mât trudeau
la personne le gouvernement trudeau
c'est que la pandémie doit demeurer sa
priorité mais il veut profiter du
discours du trône pour se montrer fidèle
à ses principes démontré qu'en pleine
crise il est encore possible d'allier
économie et environnement
ici le we be aware radio canada